what is the one thing about mixing that
people don't
[Music]
understand you know in this particular
film the dialogue we two two major
issues one is that everybody's I had to
decide what kind of accent we should
have um and I decided that everybody
should be speaking American English with
an Italian accent as if they were native
born Italians in America to learn
English but they're also brings with it
a question of intelligibility I decided
that place names should be in Italian
and proper noun should be in Italian and
spoken Italian and this outside Capital
will magically bestow its favors upon
Maserati what did that pose for you in
terms of uh intelligibility and you know
how the dialogue tracks came in when we
were working together you were also very
aware of cadences of how the Italian
Star would drop off more at the end of
the sentence and things so we did quite
a lot of volume manipulation with
certain syllables as well at the ends
too and you really are talking about
syllables is because we would drop just
the very end of a syllable of a word
recall that we we found that sometimes
shortening a vowel if if an accent
wasn't quite right particularly on an
American actor speaking Italian accented
American English if the accent it wasn't
right it was typically because they were
drawing out like an a word Chicago
Chicago when you and I first worked
together many years ago now we could
never do that on film because we
couldn't get in that close on the
magnetic tape it was our first film heat
I came in right at the very end of
mikans but heat was the one we first
worked on together yeah thinking of mod
itself one of the fun scenes that I
enjoyed doing the most for sound was
actually the Maserati time trial I can't
remember if it was fully in the script
like that where we were cutting
backwards and forwards to the church
with the mozar going back onto the
Maserati the beauty of that with the
rawness of the engine the gorgeous vocal
the gorgeous singing and then of course
we introduced all the fun of the
stopwatches they were church but really
they were listening to they heard the
gun go off for the beginning of the time
trial and they all switched their
watches on them and that was such a
great sort of Jos of all those different
sounds it was definitely one of the most
fun things to do the opera scene was
also a very special moment I thought for
sound because it was a little opposite
of what we would normally do we started
in the opera house we hear the distant
singing which Laura's hearing cuz she
hasn't gone to the Opera Jesus hearings
and she's not
there we cut to the opera house we hear
it in its beauty and by the way they
were recorded live singing so that was a
challenge but again very
authentic then we go on stage with them
and we dried it all up we took the
reverbs down a lot so we weren't
suddenly in the opera house anymore we
became more intimate and I think that
was an interesting choice that you asked
me to do but it worked so beautifully
because now suddenly you've lost a
performance and you've gone into what
they're all thinking right as you cut to
each
person as you see their eyes read
something into that my design for that
scene was to invert the performance I
wanted oper singers lit as if they were
the subjects of the scene yes and not
the actors and the camera work is very
intimate it's very verit right in their
faces as if the two characters were the
most familiar with the tener and the
soprano singing the ARA from travat then
the audience our characters Enzo Ferrari
Le lardy Michelle and Woodley what oper
does to you it invokes memory and then
what's most alive is their flashbacks
and what they're recalling and each one
it became an opportunity to explore the
backstory in totally emotional terms of
young Enzo Ferrari young Lara when Dino
was 3 four years old and and so was
dancing with the dress in the 1930s and
he's singing part of the the area so
it's like a three-way perspective all of
which has been cut through with this
Savage red car racing at you very abrupt
cut to the French Grand
Prix in this film you had to deal with
the sound of the cars and it is music
but the sound of the cars the authentic
sound of not regular commercial V12 but
full competition V12 Ferrari engines is
powerful is beautiful it's scary it's
inviting it's all these things all at
the same time
we had done a lot of temp with various
different car sounds when we were
editing always with the intention of
going back and then recording an act the
real thing which we eventually did you
want to talk about how to how we managed
the extreme Dynamics so obviously you
had to create cars that you could put
cameras in and would go at a good speed
you got them up to 100 120 milph they
would do 130 140 but obviously they
didn't have quite that sound so we were
able to access the vehicles put them out
into a a little RAC trp in England and
record just sound only so that's how we
created the sound of the real Vehicles
as far as the Dynamics go a lot of that
is down to the way that the script and
the way you shot it the way it was cut
right because it had these hard sort of
juter positions all the time which was
so great you'd get a very intense
dialogue scene which allowed us to strip
backgrounds and things out of and become
very almost claustrophobic in the drama
between the characters and then you on a
cut we'd go into full blooded Roar of
engines I mean that from a sound point
of view was actually a lot of fun to do
when we think about music that's also a
big component because how can music be
more exciting than the sound of those
real engines is it uh tackling a period
piece like this is it hard to the
specificity of the period and the
location my ambition is to bring
audience into the world the amount of De
detail and everything that I would want
to bring into it to make it complete is
vast this is where everything really
happens so you pick up a Resonance of
walking through the real place but it's
completely unchanged really and there's
nothing built after the 19th century in
the whole of three fifths of mod so
everywhere you look the cobblestone
streets everything is totally period
there's a lot of signage you had to take
off the Ferrari house is actually
Piero's house and if we walk around the
corner from the Ferrari house house
there's a barber shop where he gets
shaved every morning so Adam sat in a
chair that Enzo sat in and was shaved in
the film by the sun of the barber shed
oh my God so there was so much of that
resonance in mixing It's the final
Whiting It's the final authoring of the
movie and you have every component it's
not a script which is a blueprint of
what you want to have happen and it's
not the shooting which is so fragmented
when you're mixing it is all there for
real okay it's all all around you what
is the one thing about mixing that
people
don't understand if you notice something
then it's probably not right what I try
and aim to do is make you not notice
that we're doing anything particularly
with the soundtrack you know because if
you start to hear things that confuse
you then you've lost people Clarity is
number one to me it's always been the
same way I Mak in a very traditional
style as you know it's about making sure
that it's very clear the story line The
Narrative the atmosphere are very
important around that and then of course
the music the music choices the M where
the music comes in where it goes out
they're all signals that you're supposed
to pay attention to subconsciously if
it's in the wrong place you notice it
for the wrong reasons so what I try and
do every day is make something as
seamless and as meant to be as it can be
for that story it's the flow of the
narrative through times absolutely and
the rhythm of that flow from quiet
scenes to loud scenes to when you have
the J the position of but Dynamic Sound
coming in that's what's particularly
exciting that I rely on you very much to
be able to calm me down and keep it in I
do my best and often you and I will sit
and we'll go through something and then
you'll go back and make an adjustment in
the editing room with the picture right
because it only becomes apparent while
we're mixing sound that the picture
needs to have an adjustment when we mix
I move the editing rooms on the mixing
stage basically in adjacent rooms so
that we can make yeah constant
adjustment it really is totally it's
interactive and organ
it's very much alive it's the best of
times when I get to park the car in
front of the Sound Stage go in and I'm
there every minute with you and it's
really it's a real pleasure I keep look
I always look forward to well me too get
to that point thank you it's been great
talking to you thank you so much yeah
you're
[Music]
welcome